while joining me now to assess the
situation on the ground is retired Air
Vice Marshal Sean Bell and advisor at
Universal defense and Security Solutions
and John just referring back to Liz
truss's speech that she gave last night
she talks about pushing Russia out of
the whole of Ukraine how realistic is
that because of course that includes
Crimea yeah there's important speech I
think and she's playing to a number of
different audiences on behalf of British
government obviously the International
Community trying to Galvanize support
but also president zielinski a a very
key issue of support I think the
ambition of ejecting Uh Russian out of
Ukraine completely is not entirely
realistic not least which in the donbass
um the Russians have been in that region
for the last 10 years on the Eastern
side of it that about 30 percent are
Russian native Russian speaking and
it'll be quite difficult I think there's
quite a lot of Russian sympathize in
that part of the country and down the
Crimea
um that the key issue here is the port
of Sebastopol because for Generations
hundreds of years is that it's been
strategically important for Russia and
it's very hard to see they'll give that
up without a fight so I'm not entirely
sure that's realistic but there is a
talk about returning to the pre-24th of
February lines and I think that's
probably a more realistic aspiration the
other thing that Liz truss was talking
about was galvanizing enthusiasm from
the International Community for
providing weapons there's an urgent need
for heavy weapons as president zielinski
said and getting more of those weapons
into country is key the danger is it
starts to distract when it starts to
about tanks and this time combat
aircraft most of those tanks have are
packed full of electronic equipment take
a lot of training before they can be
used effectively and combat aircraft
it's years of training to be able to use
those so it's hard to see how those can
really be operated effectively I mean
while we're hearing from Ukraine that
Russia is making some gains in the East
what is going on there yeah I think when
we look at the donbass the Russians have
got a pretty long front 300 mile front
and they've reverted to their usual
attack which is to do lots of heavy
pounding with artillery and mortars for
just to weaken the enemy and then find a
point of weakness and then surge through
that point of weakness the Ukrainian
resistance has been incredible and quite
wisely they've seeded a bit of ground
along the way but they are inflicting
quite a lot of casualties on the
Russians as they go but I think what
this illustrates is there's such an
urgent need for artillery
um because the Russians have got a
massive artillery pounding the
ukrainians the ukrainians need to be
doing the same in Reverse The Americans
have committed around 100 pieces of 155
millimeter artillery which is brilliant
so you sort of say well that's all 1950s
technology why is that going to help the
ukrainians already got old Soviet kit
the key is if you marry that gun up with
a Fire Control radar you can now see
where the rounds are coming from you
couldn't Target the specific uh
um location of your enemy gun and now
you can adjust your fire because these
things far over 10 miles and now be much
more Precision effect rather than just
aerial denial and it could have a really
decisive effect on the battle the
challenge is it's one thing to commit to
sending these things there it's quite
another getting them into theater into
the hands of people get the training
committed get the ammunition there and
have them actually being used in
conflict that time is critical at the
moment
I made to the reports that we've heard
about explosions in Moldova over the
last couple of days yeah the dangerous
sometimes because it's obviously world
to the west of the country the dangerous
it's interpreted as are the Russians
going to build a bridge from their
current situation on the Baltic Coast
across to molds over and transnisteria
there's about 1500 Russian troops there
they've got lots of old equipment and
whilst yes it could be an ambition for
the Russians to move further over in
reality to do that they'd have to extend
their reach past person take a desk and
move in ukrainians have already been
pushing back on Kirsten Odessa is very
well fortified it looks really unlikely
that's realistic particularly at the
moment given the Russians are massively
committed in the donbass region